hi there Steve Kaufman here hello Steve
Kaufman I have my sound on it's a new
year I'm glad to be back although I had
a lovely time skiing with my family my
wife and I my son my daughter-in-law her
grandchildren he spent a week skiing a
big white in British Columbia I did both
downhill and cross-country had a great
time I feel rejuvenated so I'm gonna
start up again on my usual blog here I
talk about different aspects of language
learning today I posted something on my
on my blog because I had a message on
the blog and someone said send me
English learning listening practice
audio files such as mp3 thank you well
you know we get this all the time people
email us they put comments on my blog or
on other places and they say you know
I'm trying to learn English please help
me send me stuff or 70 some CDs or 70
mp3 files and I must say that you know
this has been going on for months and
months I find it extremely annoying
I would there is no way I would help
that person who is this person is it my
my relative my cousin is it my friend is
it someone who has helped me or even
helped someone else I have no idea who
this person is what I know is that this
person has no initiative because if it's
a matter of English there's just an
abundance of content on the web you want
to find audio on the web go and look for
it you want to find text on the way up
you want to find anything this person
even if I sent them the mp3 file I mean
he or she would do nothing with it if
there's one thing I've learned about
language learning or any other activity
if you aren't motivated enough to get up
and look for yourself without bothering
other people you aren't going to achieve
anything it's that simple in my book I
have this
reference to drums of the Chinese Taoist
philosopher and drones us parable of the
crooked tree and of course a crooked
tree may appear cooked into the wood
from the crooked tree making you may
think it's a no use for anything but the
crooked tree followed its own nature and
managed to go out and follow its
interests and do things for itself and
it's an individual it's not a tree in
amongst a whole bunch of similar trees
in the plantation forest it's a tree
with character and with personality find
your own way don't bother people and if
you are going to first begin by
contributing and after you have
contributed after you have put in you
can expect to get out and you know this
reminds me of my own experience now with
portuguese even though I've been
studying Russia I some while ago I found
a Portuguese audiobook site our
believers from tocome or whatever it and
I sent away and I ordered a bunch of
books have a bunch of audio books and
after much back and forth I finally got
them and I am delighted and one of the
audiobooks that I see these that I
ordered was a series of essays by a
Brazilian educator whose name is little
bear Alice and I have really been
enjoying listening to these and I
googled on the Internet Ruben Alves and
as you can see on my blog the linguist
on language the linguist marcom you can
see a reference to a blog that has texts
for these things that I'm listening to
so while I listen to them in my car and
I listen to them on our iPad on their
things
understand or don't understand all of a
sudden have the text I can import them
into link I am as happy as can be and lo
and behold one of the first bits of
content that I come across and which is
on my CD and which is also available at
this blog site called Ruben Alma's blog
non-official and the first item here is
our Tillett producer for me the art of
creating hunger and there's a lengthy
essay about how the role of an educator
is to create hunger in the student
create an interest in the student and
that all of the things that we create in
our lives in a sense are extensions of
our bodies and lubimov Eze describes how
as a child he wanted to steal fruit from
the neighbor's yard because there was a
branch that was more or less accessible
so he had to create a special tool in
order to be able to reach the fruit so
that he could bring it in but it was his
desire his hunger for the fruit that
caused him to create the tool to invent
something to create something get that
fruit to bring it to himself and the
role of an educator is to create that
hunger within people so that they will
find the means they will create the
tools they will look they will find and
thereby they will learn and until you
light the fire until you create the
hunger as ruga magua's says giving
people things in a classroom lecturing
them telling them giving them rules none
of this is as effective as creating that
hunger so the people will find things
for themselves and that's why I find
that this kind of message that I
received from this one person you know
send me some mp3 files thank you you
know not at
that I would do that we are doing our
thing at link a lot of it is free of
course we would like to eventually be
self-supporting we have this dream that
it can be but meantime we're
constructing something we're
contributing something we're giving
something many people are using it and
enjoying it you know use what we've
already set up don't come at me and say
send me some mp3 files link is full of
mp3 there's 2,000 items there that you
just have to download how badly do you
need to be spoon-fed
that's the major problem with formal
education it's based on the assumption
that the student needs to be spoon-fed
that until the student comes into
contact with a teacher the student is
incapable of doing anything no if you
aren't motivated if you don't have
hunger you aren't gonna get anywhere and
the role of the educator is to create
that hunger
thank you to Dhruva Marvis I am
listening and I'm very much enjoying
listening to his Portuguese you know
audiobooks and I hope to be doing some
Portuguese podcasts in the near future
talking to some of our Portuguese
speaking learners via Skype and putting
that up I want to speak very much we get
the Portuguese speakers to speak 98% of
the time so that our Portuguese learners
people who are learning Portuguese can
use this for their own learning so there
you have it that's my rant for this
evening and I look forward to as usual
input from all and sundry